ne mélangeons pas les torchons et les
serviettes ni le roi du fast food avec
le roi de la gastronomie française paul
bocuse n'a pas apprécié du tout de voir
sa prestigieuse toc et celles de cinq
autres grands chefs internationaux
photographiée dans sa cuisine de
collonges utilisé à la gloire du big mac
aussi le big boss français de montils
réparation et excuses pour cet outrage
cette affiche en version mac donald
c'est une photo prise dans les cuisines
de paul bocuse à collonges au mont d'or
elle a été placardées aux pays-bas dans
plusieurs établissements à l'enseigne du
numéro un du fast food américain et cela
a coïncidé en même temps excusez du peu
avec le dernier sommet européen de
maastricht paul bocuse a du mal à
digérer le big mac vous avez cinq
clients qui m'a mené une photo et je
pensais qu'il faisait un gars d'une part
j'ai dit mais c'est pas possible
associé à mcdonald's je me suis
renseigné et dans tous les restaurants
il y avait là c'est un poster de
mcdonald's et quand je vois que j'allume
propose un big mac
je bondis alors moralité on à pirater
votre image
oui surtout que je dépose mon image de
marque et mon nom dans le monde entier
ces propos que mcdonald's l'utilisent je
ne dis pas que mcdonald's mcdonald's
c'est peut-être de bons produits mais
enfin c'est pas encore pas sur la même
distance ni dans la même catégorie
alors qu'elle suit vous allez donner à
cette affaire et bien j'ai voulu mettre
souliers pour défendre les intérêts et
je pense que je m'en vais demander des
dédommagements qui vont être versés à
l'école des arts culinaires d'écurie et
pour nous on pourra former les chefs de
demain